I don't wanna see many shows other than
what I've been trying to stream lately
all I have to use is Rumble now and a
full mug Club
[Music]
s
be wondering what's so damn funny what
happened to Samantha Bee
I don't wanna be anything other than
free
[Music]
and Stephen Hawking hands and he drops
ball I'm sorry I forgot you were
Mr Perfect hey you're talking to a D1
scholarship athlete who took us to
over a scapegoat grab a mirror break it
and swallow the shards a-hole hey
everyone just needs a chill it'll all
work out these are supposed to be the
best years of Our Lives foreign
[Music]
free
join mug club today for 89 annually to
support content like this and get access
to the entire network louder with
crowder.com
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
pops uh man there's a lot to get to
today this is a busy show it is a busy
show but it's the kind of show we live
for so the Epstein logs now have
revealed a little bit more oops than we
anticipated so that's fun uh I think my
I don't know if I because of my my red
tide but my ears feel like the
headphones are normal they're normal
most days but not today we'll be talking
about uh Brittany greiner's comments
that she just made it uh should be a a
crime to ban the the men from beating up
women and uh also the White House
correspondent Center was really really
bad but there are some Freudian slips
there that are hilarious yes it'll be
fun to make fun of and we have another
installment of the Flying V versus Chuck
Todd which really isn't fair but no so
it's it's a mix it's kind of a potluck
there's a lot to get to we'll try and
cover all of it but the eps sting logs
that's that's revelatory is that the
right word maybe it's the beginning of
the end who do you think is the biggest
name to be revealed on Epstein's list
and with what frequency the weirdest
thing to me is the consistent Kevin
Spacey Chris Tucker Bill Clinton combo
if they all traveled there together they
all travel together what like the like
the three pedophile tears
get off at least on the last part of
your phrase because you say man uh so uh
we have that more to get to and of
course Gerald some people don't know why
you're Gerald a but we'll get to that
how are you sir I'm doing well how are
you I'm I'm happy for a lot of reasons
it's a fun day it's gonna be looking
forward to the show yeah uh and also
about I don't really have much to
promote because of course in third chair
if you hear this theme music right here
you know who it is oh there it is okay
yeah
yeah it was also that was a that was
Brittany Greiner she used to Moonlight
there's a theory
there are two today this is something
right now we talked with you about this
because a lot of people are saying hey
you know we signed up to mug Club maybe
you didn't receive your mug at one point
in time or uh you weren't able to
transfer over or Reef we get it I've
spoken with a lot of you about this and
Alex Jones
the garage and they're saying like hey
what I want to sign back up and I
already signed up only a few months ago
so
we don't know where you we can't reach
you but we are trying to do our best to
do right by you so if you signed up for
any conserve right-leaning streaming
platform if you have a membership to any
of those within the last 12 months you
just send your proof of purchase to free
mug Club at lotto's crowder.com you can
actually send your screenshot and people
will manually review it and give you
three months free of monthly try it you
don't like it bounce take off
any other conservative right-leaning
streaming service send in your proof of
purchase your membership to Fremont club
at ladder with credit.com that means you
don't have to stop those and you get to
watch ours concurrently and decide what
it is that you want to do Nick depalo's
worth it alone absolutely and it's
before today I know what you're saying
don't go out there and subscribe it has
to be before today for today and don't
contact Rumble this is go through that
email address that is it free mug Club
at latroscredit.com free for three
months proof of anywhere else there you
go that's well it's a start so
let's get to this first thing the games
begin in Boston Satan con goers this is
the thing everything's con now do you
notice that remember pop scrotter when
you uh I thought you took me to Comic it
took me to weebcon remember that one
yeah it's like do you want to apologize
on air
convention oh and we end up with a bunch
of fat anime ladies in Mortal Kombat
songs it was scary it was terrifying
it's the stuff of children's nightmares
so anyway
now it's Satan Khan and the Satan Khan
goers decided to uh you know in an act
of defiance and bravery Shred the Bible
police flag I warn you if you're
offended by this here's the thing I'm
not idiots uh are just bringing it upon
themselves but notice they always you
say like why do you say why do you say
that uh Satanist must uh hate uh America
well let me kind of give you an idea
here they are shredding Flags the Bible
during their opening ritual uh while
chanting all four of them hail Satan
that was the part about me
she hates her father
it's mutual
[Music]
[Applause]
was that an Under Armor flag no it was a
police flag we hate the police all right
okay but we like free speech all right
well how do you make sure that our
people don't kick your ass I don't know
I look like a walking Johnny Depp 16
bracelet Hot Topic rotating jacket
I never grew out of it now now do the
Quran you know what you don't even do
the Quran do Hadith yeah just had these
yeah you really want to have balls go
for this hey I'm I'm a Christian you're
a Christian yeah yeah uh any of you
bothered by them doing that no I think
it's stupid you're just giving so much
credibility to what you're tearing up
have you ever torn up a satanic bible
the satanic verse anything like that
have you ever felt compelled to go out
and do that I did it with an US Weekly
once then
they labeled Barack the best looking man
in America
exactly
you're basically saying that's really
true and I don't like you you're saying
this book is so important that I'm going
to destroy one oh my God there's 18
billion more I don't know how how do we
do this the most printed book of all
time and I stole this one from the hotel
that's right
it's a Gideon
Gerald nailed it it's because it's so
significant it matters you guys comment
below I mean look of course the Bible's
but it's it's words right it's inspired
word of God it's not like it's like you
rip it up and God's like wow well what
am I going now how do I reach people
what do I do there's a coupon in the
back
in Revelations there's the Charles Atlas
after getting sand castle Behold a
jacked horse
if you like this let me also recommend
yes exactly other titles by this author
ah she ruined my algorithm
by the way this is a live show Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern of course
you can watch gun Rumble if you're
watching on YouTube I don't know why you
can listen to the podcast and audio
where there's exclusive Lost Tapes I've
been going to Spotify and uh it's not
iTunes it's Apple now Friday is only on
Mud Club another thing you get Nick
depalo you get them four days a week you
get a Friday show you get comedy
specials coming down the pike guns and
gear guns and gears first video last
week I like the gear now I've got good
gear I mean that's that's not a piano
that's a good point Brittany Greiner
okay so Brittany grinder and I have to
be clear I didn't we did not edit this
at all at all you're going to say we
slowed down the audio no I mean this
this woman gives she gives Scarlett
Johansson a run for her mind
I'm a superhero guys look at my black
leather outfit so
press conference your sounded forced I
know mine sounded forced that's just her
it's her Essence Brittany Greiner said
that it should be a crime and this is
how far we've gone right remember the
slippery slope was like ah just let
people do what they want as adults okay
but now she wants it to be a crime for
you likely as a parent to ban males from
competing in women's sports where is
that going to be on your radar in terms
of advocating for that's a low voice um
it is yeah
oh I mean that that rains High
things that I'll be fighting for and
speaking up against everyone has
everyone deserves the right to play
everyone deserves the right to to come
here sit in these seats and feel safe
and not feel
um
they can't be who they are or
um like like it's just all eyes on them
uh so
um
I think it's
a crime honestly to oh
she should know separate
um someone
for any reason so I definitely will be
speaking up against against those that
legislation and those laws that are
trying to be passed for sure yeah she
also went on to uh produce a verse about
how she used to read Word Up Magazine it
was all a dream I used to read Word Up
magazines it is uncanny now this is how
inarticulate she is yes she is because
she says and people shouldn't be
excluded for any reason oh everyone has
the right to compete really really
everyone people aren't eliminated for
other reasons all the time from Sports
think about weight limits that now not
only weight classes and wrestling there
are weight limits depending on high
school football weren't you you almost
didn't make it well yeah I had to had to
go on a fat kid diet for like a month
before weigh-ins really all the time
because I was just so big yeah I wasn't
like super fat but I was so tall
compared to my classmates yeah thanks a
lot
guzzle down sweets
[Laughter]
look you look bad and you should feel
bad
here's the thing she says it should be a
crime now keep in mind it may also be a
crime for you not allow your children to
transition right this is the language
they used it should be a crime for
doctors to not provide gender affirming
care now it should be a crime and I
guess these are just words but today's
words are tomorrow's policies a crime to
not allow males to compete in women's
sports so let me go through some lists
as well and that seems a bit
self-serving it does seem yeah well
she'll think it's a crime when she runs
into a pick from a Charles Barkley type
well player I think she'd hold her own
what do you mean that'd be like running
into a mirror you know I know I know
basketball is a non-contact sport but it
can get a little rough out there it'll
get rough if you're that big of a woman
well she's tall so here are some things
that uh that that should either our
crimes or maybe should be crimes let's
go through the definition so I don't
know I think pretending to be a woman uh
and concussing a real woman should be a
crime
watch it that's a man
[Applause]
it sounds like a scream in a haunted
house
[Laughter]
it's horrible look we're only laughing
to to quell the pain it's horrible in
her nose
oh yeah that Dad rightfully probably
wants to kick that female's ass I mean
the guy who just spiked the ball into by
the way this was so bad we also have the
reverse angle of that Spike yeah
[Music]
and drowning that makes sense you can't
even do common anymore because it's real
[Laughter]
it's real
biggie is saying that men should be able
to spike into women's faces otherwise it
should be a crime let me surprised her
head didn't fall off if you disagree
with what Brittany Greiner just said
just hit the like button hit the like
button and comment below do you think it
should be a crime to prevent men from
competing in women's sports or do you
think it should be a crime for men to
compete in women's sports this is kind
of a binary decision
yeah
I think it's also should be crime to
pretend to be a woman break a real
woman's skull right this also happened
with Fallon Fox uh also what actually is
a crime though this isn't should be a
crime pretending to be a woman and
sneaking weed into Russia the state
department says it's aware of the arrest
of an American citizen in Moscow WNBA
All-Star Brittany Greiner was apparently
detained last month come on this video
released by Russian Customs appears to
show Griner at moscow's airport
authorities say they found Vape
cartridges in her luggage containing an
oil derived from Cannabis which is
illegal in Russia surprise surprise hash
oil is illegal in Russia who knew this
is the level of entitlement that you see
from so many American women I'm going to
do whatever I'm going to bring my vape
pen to Russia guess what you're going to
be arrested in Russia good by the way no
word on whether or not we've gotten back
The Merchant of death we traded for
Brittany grinder hmm Griner that was a
Freudian slip yeah by the way it should
also be a crime I think it should be a
crime to ban a man from being first lady
I don't think that that's fair yep that
is Deontay Wilder and Michelle Obama
oh my gosh order turned to the back
please
and flex you know she complained that
she had to go to Russia to to make a
million bucks because of pay and equity
and but what is she what did she do in I
don't even know what she did in Russia I
guess they had some kind of Russian
League other than get arrested we're
starting to make the case for them being
paid the same as NBA oh good yeah yes
payer legal he has to go to Russia to
get money yeah that's who's our stands
are empty what she just didn't do the
conversion she didn't realize it was a
million rupals ah it's like twenty
dollars yeah
I can't buy hash I can't buy hash oil
because do all those movie players sound
like that I'll be sober for a month a
million rubles in a prison sentence that
was a bad deal it was a bad deal and
they can they just basically confiscated
the money too right yeah exactly that's
right that's how they do it in Russia do
we need to move a pop subscribers might
cluster to him do you think they're
Yakuza or a little bit because he sounds
a little it sounds you don't need to be
afraid you got that wonderful buttery
soft voice it does did I already tell
people hit the rumble button you did
okay you died again we did it again
you did nothing here's the thing too
I guarantee this has already happened
but if we are on YouTube and you are
watching on YouTube and you hear and see
this
that means head on over to rumble
because we're not going to self-censor
you now we're joking about this because
we like to have a laugh but here's the
problem here's the problem today's words
are tomorrow's policies and this person
is within Striking Distance or within
spiking distance of the White House of
the people who who set legislative
policy keep in mind the former Vice
President Joe Biden said that he thought
it was cruel to not offer gender
affirming care to minors so naturally
Greiner this existed in an echo chamber
in a vacuum it wouldn't matter was
celebrated by former Vice President Joe
Biden at the White House correspondence
dinner on Saturday tonight
unlike last year
Brittany Greiner share with her wife
Cheryl
Brittany
great where are you kid stand up come on
as if we couldn't Point her out when she
was seated
hard all of us were fighting for your
release listen to this cheese but it's
great to have you home
and boys
I can hardly wait to see you back on the
court kids
remember your promise I guess you put my
granddaughter my All-State girl to see
you right
now
I just want to make sure in context did
he just say boys
and boys
I can hardly wait to see you back on the
court kids
not to be fair in his defense he did
just finish the his annual White House
viewing of Lost Boys
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
is that the granddaughter from the pole
dancer from Hunter or is that the one
he's oh ouch good question I don't know
if he acknowledges that one anymore or
whether one he was showering with yeah
oh that was his daughter that's his own
daughter yeah that's his own daughter
that also doesn't narrow it down but he
also refers to all of them as uh he
doesn't refer them as boys but I don't
know this is the Jerry Springer family
look you can say what you want about
Donald Trump sure Donald Trump obviously
has his issues but Donald like his kids
love him he's very close with his kids
and he didn't shower with any of them
I mean that's the start that's good I
mean you should at least start it's baby
steps yes baby steps
also the name of the also the name of
the annual White House viewing party he
also he watches baby stuff so Biden also
by the way addressed the detainment of
the Wall Street Journal writer uh Evan
gershkovich to the entire family
everyone in this
stands with you
we're working every day to secure his
release
there you are looking at other
opportunities and tools to bring him
home get right on it we keep the faith
now let's go to the after party yeah to
be fair also is to keep that people
thought that was an inappropriate keep
the faith to be fair he did just finish
the annual White House viewing of Billy
Joel's music video keeping faith
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you have any other merchants of death
laying around just trade one of them for
the journal list
I think you could have traded him for
everyone being held in Russia that
should be freed right now exactly you
think you'd get a few picks and NBA play
or W sorry sorry I keep saying that she
should just go to the NBA because I
think she'd be fine there and yeah
[Music]
that's fair
Trader for future considerations of
other people yeah obtained yeah after we
arrest one of your guys then we'll you
know this is the thing people forget it
gets memory hold just okay you need to
trade a major bargain you have any more
International arms dealers and murderers
around something to use as leverage
against Russia you were able to get
Brittany Greiner back but this
journalist by the way who has a family
waiting for him who didn't break the law
who didn't break the law and and by the
way this is this is a huge part this is
important this is this is breaking
Unwritten Rules of Engagement arresting
journalists you're not even supposed to
do that during wartime just to be clear
yeah only fascist countries do that
right evil countries do that we don't
that's usually something that raises our
cackles yeah that shows you the
priorities right keep the faith we're
doing everything in our power to get
this no you're not I'm sorry no you're
not you got a WNBA player who actually
committed a crime in Russia that is
punishable by their laws if we don't
like it that's fine we can say we don't
like it but she was in their country
right home court rules baby you got to
go with that and a journalist that's
been over there so to make people happy
on your side of the aisle you said well
let's go after the the lesbian WNBA
player and make sure she comes home as
opposed to a journalist because God
forbid he's actually white and has a
wife well you know what else the
journalist doesn't serve as a tool for
legislative policy Brittany Greiner is
going to come back and Champion the
transitioning not only children cause
but allowing men and women sports right
basically destroying Title IX Brittany
Greiner is a political activist and Joe
Biden knew that and she's a political
activist for the left we don't know that
about Evan probably isn't a conservative
my guess works for the Wall Street
Journal but probably wasn't going to
come back and watch call me to the mat
on this at some point you are going to
see Brittany Greiner also support
transitioning children this is all about
the kids and by knows it and he said so
that's why we traded The Merchant of
death for Brittany Greiner and this man
still sits there and people forget about
it don't allow it to be forgotten don't
allow it to be what is Brittany Greiner
just uh have a go at the NBA
start her in any game against any team
yeah good just you know nothing real
serious not a game seven yeah something
mild season let's make it easy this is
good college go to One Go college and
then see like you can kind of work your
way it's like Adam Sandler going back to
school right when he had to do that he
had to go back through the grades you
can just start in college
Jack and Brittany Greiner yes I'm just
here college basketball
another man I am a woman that's a three
I don't know if she'd get a point a
point no it would be rough you can't lay
up in this league sorry could get in a
well probably be laying up the towel
girls yeah she's what six eight
ah something it's not quite a reach
she's tall for a woman the average NBA
male is six seven this is average right
so up front like the likes of Jason Kidd
in the past and Spud Webb lowering the
averages yes significantly yeah the five
fivers running around what's the average
height of a takeaway Spud Webb and Mugsy
bugs it's uh like seven foot five so we
don't know Gerald in the NBA is called
Stumpy yeah
um Brittany Greiner is six nine oh my
goodness really wow still can't dunk
wow wow that is so telling that is so
telling not enough explosive muscular
generation to stuff the ball at six nine
she doesn't have the motor recruitment I
could be wrong she may be it just
doesn't happened very often oh she
definitely stops it yeah well you know
what I mean I do admire that the good
the good three-point shots from what a
three-point shot yes from a woman is the
same as from you know an NBA yes exactly
no that's true same hand eye same
distance granny shot though sometimes
yeah three-point shots it goes in three
point shot is a three-point shot weather
it's it's penis or vagina we all agree
unless I do it with their penis in which
case extra points there should be a five
points that zelinsky can do that so the
lines moved in in the play the piano so
Dr basketball I also watched a guy lift
an entire Clark bar with his wiener one
time yeah I can nail it you weren't
supposed to tell people yeah I'm sorry
okay I can hammer a nail into a board so
this is again the memory hole that where
everyone here is celebrating Brittany
Greiner so they forget about this man
who was wasting away likely being abused
tortured in a Russian prison so that we
here can have the White House
correspondence dinner and I don't know
if you remember this but White House
correspondence dinners used to be where
it was friendly but they used to take
some Jabs at the sitting present or
sitting former vice president uh in this
case not so much but there were a couple
so here's actually one example that I do
you know fair play a comedian took aim
at uh Joe Biden's age it's crazy to
think that Joe Biden is only one
heartbeat away from no one taking him
seriously as president
sorry for that one
that was oh wait sorry that was actually
from nine years ago that's right never
mind
that was an actuary tables joke from
nine years ago
and the band's going to be running again
Joe McHale was a child yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
so this year instead uh Joe Biden former
vice president went full cringe and he
leaned in declared himself trying to be
funny and look I don't have to think
it's funny but I acknowledged it was a
joke he called himself dark Brandon
Roy
apart him is yours
I'm going to be fine with your jokes
but I'm not sure about dark Brandon
[Applause]
it's really gonna stumble
now look here there's no time you can't
deliver what do we do guys uh the
Ray-Bans go with the Ray-Bans are these
those blue blockers I love those
and of course here's the thing right the
left they did this with fake news a lot
of you don't remember this don't let the
memory hold us fake news was something
that they tried to use right they tried
to use and refer to any conservative
news as fake news and the right took it
and co-opted it and they tried to get it
back the left has been much less
successful in attempting the same kind
of maneuver trying to co-opt the meme of
dark Brandon since this last summer
Biden even used the meme in his 2024
campaign on t-shirts and he actually
likes the meme so much he even
incorporated into some of his yeah uh
scratch and sniff campaign Flyers so
that was yeah it was oh geez oh no don't
finish the job I did not like the job no
I'm not like that Joe I hate seeing that
and here's the thing too is is people
talk about bullies right let's be okay
what is bullying bullying is a pilot
bullying is when you're picking on
someone who doesn't have the ability to
fight back now everyone knows that
Tucker Carlson is a very popular uh
figure himself but Tucker Carlson
obviously I guarantee you his invitation
got lost in the mail was not there at
the white house uh correspondence dinner
and so they together with a room full of
people who think exactly as they do they
never value into they only value
diversity of skin color of gender never
that of intellectual diversity
um they decided to do a pylon and take
aim at Tucker Carlson we really have a
record to be proud of
vaccinated the nation
transformed the economy
heard historic legislative victories and
mid-term results but the job isn't
finished
I mean
it is finished for Tucker Carlson
[Applause]
what do you warning about like that
like you think that's not reasonable
give me a break
first off first off so much this what
why is the Asian from Jurassic Park
there that's right go
[Music]
there aren't there aren't enough
sycophants
out there she was like even like even
like uh Sheryl Crow's not going to show
up huh give me the guy who screwed up
the eggs in Jurassic Park I like that
guy he was gay put him there right put
him from the center I like his flat top
I love that guy and there here's the
thing when we we've done closing time
obviously right now this is an
entertainment show this is a comedy show
and of course we make all the references
available a lot of credit.com but our
primary goal is to keep you entertained
informed and then you can research as
much as you want when we do the closing
time for example with Don Lemon
understand the context here when he says
it's done for Tucker Carlson
it's as though Joe Biden doesn't
understand that the internet exists
it's off cable who's gonna see him now
nobody nowhere left to talk and he reach
anyone is he gonna ham right now ah he's
done
Tucker's first tweet after his
separation with Fox News received in its
first day
[Music]
thank you
Fox News just you wait yeah now that he
can go and speak freely it is going to
get worse before it gets better for you
sir yes you wonder how that tweet would
have been uh treated if Elon didn't have
that's a good point oh of course would
that have ever gotten would have been
New York Post story yeah Hunter Biden
laptop story and that's a very good
point Jill here they see these as
legislative accomplishments why well you
see gensaki you see car didn't jump yeah
them talking about how they are working
with big Tech organizations they are
working with media organizations to
remove misinformation by the way you may
not like everything people get things
wrong we get things wrong Tucker Carlson
has gotten things wrong but to act as
though Tucker Carlson is a purveyor of
misinformation he's the only person back
then on cable news who covered January
6th accurately and we did it on this
show the week after and we did a
three-hour stream several months later
when they were going to be holding their
hearings and they didn't because of the
weather this this is something in
another state yes in another state not
not even close to them think about this
for a second yeah I skimmed over it I
didn't write it down as a note
legislative accomplishments and then it
is done for Tucker yeah that is there
that is fascist that's the goal of the
government to eliminate voices from
media that they don't like more proof of
that again the political entertainment
media industrial complex they all work
together like Nick to Paula says I think
there's uh 10 guys in a room he's not
that far off no I agree because you hear
what former Vice President Biden just
said now do you also remember how the
media responded When Donald Trump would
address or attack the media they would
silence him too it's one thing to say
the Press is liberal it's one thing to
say the ninth circuit is liberal but
when you start saying that somebody has
uh is an enemy of the people then that
does incite people to violence
especially if it's coming from the
president United States
but you can call the president of the
United States the enemy of the people
you can call Republicans the enemy of
the people and do it behind this really
demonic looking red background like Joe
Biden did in that speech you can do that
and it's totally fine is it just because
it hits too close to home and you don't
want to be revealed for who you are Joe
yeah and also here's an important note
if you go back to a change my mind I
talked about this because at that point
in time
the Press being the enemy of the people
was a Stalin quote it wasn't a Donald
Trump quote yeah then when they started
quoting him that way he responded as he
did indignant like it is here to be
other people
so he responded that way and now they
have a question right now they have the
quote the initial quote was not the it
was not those exact words they were not
those words the media quoted Solomon are
trying to attribute it to Trump with any
respondent said you know what in this
case yes let's go with it and now they
act as though oh Stalin Donald Trump but
what's really more pervasive is what you
see with Joe Biden and hey Tucker
Carlson's done the difference is here's
a silver lining here's where you pick up
some wins they don't know
they don't know about the internet I
don't know that they know about how many
of you are on rumble on a regular basis
anyone can do something once doing it
day in day out day in day out that's
what's happening right now on Rumble
YouTube is going to be a shell of itself
it is going to be an irrelevant shell of
its former self that's why you can watch
on Rumble and I I want to watch them
wither away now if there's one clip that
also highlights the self-importance it's
nothing but virtue signaling at the
White House Press uh White House what is
it White House Correspondence Dinner
whatever it is it's not the Gridiron
thing I know there's a bad
Correspondence Dinner there's a pancake
breakfast yes there is so many stupid
things that's not the legislative agenda
well the pancake the pancake prayer
breakfast remember that was supposed to
be just sort of like inconsequential
like go out and be like uh thank you for
the food we eat thank you for the birds
that sing but then Ben Carson went out
and was like the Quran is not
reconcilable with the Constitution they
were like what the
we're trying to eat
came out yesterday
but do it in a very low voice
and I'm going to clip you off and pick
you up and pick you up have fun and
that's how Ben Carson broke into the
spotlight
remember that remember when everyone's
going remember this thing you just just
did it like it was supposed to be people
like at the pancake breakfast your
potion and then my mom sitting next to
him was like what yes
I would kill you if I were in the
country where I could you should be dead
right now yeah it was really like we all
uh we're out here we all pray to the
same God he's like I don't pray to your
God
I don't pray to your false prophet God I
said it
and then the media went after him
remember he was an Uncle Tom he wasn't
black enough the guy grew up in Detroit
to a single mother household and tried
to stab her and she was saved by her
belt buckle this guy was on The A Team
for black guys okay if you want to talk
about the black experience
all right
so if there's one I'm just I like then
good grades yeah it's bullied for
getting him go to school you know but he
had a slow seething rage where then he
would try and stab him yeah he's an
idiot who separated conjoined twins yeah
because that's easy yeah he got an A in
fashioning he's an okay doctor I
guess yeah he said okay I don't know how
hard it is to separate conjoined twins
grape seed oil a paper cutter call it a
day a YouTube video right
I didn't say it when they go back to my
19 bathrooms with chandeliers you ever
see his house
oh my gosh Saddam Hussein with that it
was the most pimped out house I'd ever
seen okay
with their giant portraits of himself
yes really yeah and that's me that's
okay I'm gonna I love Ben Carson till
the day I die because of what he did
back then so if there's one clip though
with this correspondence that are of the
self-righteousness uh that is on display
and is highlighted by any sort of one
crystallized clip I would say it's
Chrissy teigen's entrance here you go
three people
[Music]
it's also very revealing
and by the way those people carrying the
back of her dress
they don't look
like were those people hired to carry
the back of her dress or was it like
Simon like Carrie's cross with her dress
I mean they don't look like they were
there in an official capacity it's just
some woman in a sweater with a purse it
looks like her help is what it looks
like it's like she's saying I need
people this and you do this at your
wedding to make sure that it kind of
flows correctly right just let you and
by the way they dropped it at the end
there and everything's fine I know was
she walking across spikes that she's
gonna get caught on
don't understand I carry a wedding dress
I mean for some yes self-entitled person
going to Correspondence Dinner yeah by
the way the the still photos and do not
look them up are not flattering no
especially in front of listen I took an
informal poll of the gals of the gals
out out front and you know they're not
fans they don't think she's the Chrissy
type of beauty that she's held out to be
yeah for crying out loud she has she has
cheek implants that make her look like
lady Lane around the Merry-Go-Round
oh my goodness have you seen it's like
somebody's sticking out yeah no it is
and I wasn't saying that I was saying
that I am basically
imagine wearing a robe and now imagine
somebody carrying the back of it right
it pulls it apart in the front it's not
a good look no it's not it's not and by
the way this is one of the women out
there you don't need to do this yeah
look you don't need to do this I know
the left will try and say fat and obese
is beautiful but let me tell you
something you don't need fake lips you
don't need fake cheeks guys normal
average straight meals are not the ones
who want you to do this it's the fashion
it's the same left to social Engineers
who tell you that it's fine to be obese
so long as you have fake stuff in your
face you don't need any of it it doesn't
make you look better it makes you look
weird we don't expect that of you we
don't want you to look like a doll we
think that you're beautiful as you are
within the parameters of Health really
this is one thing that I hope women out
there especially someone who has a
daughter you you are take care
foreign
[Music]
I beg to differ a bit our makeup gal
this morning she had a lot of extra work
to do on me she she likes makeup that's
not it was like a car accident yeah
she was wondering what went wrong she
spent more time on you than they did on
Clint Howard
she had a trial it was just vulgar
all right so this is going to hurt
plastic mixer and you guys
you guys can let us know uh if you watch
the dinner and and uh and you know what
I would love to hear from you women out
there look I hate that you feel pressure
to change who you are physically beyond
what you can control here's thing you
can control your weight right you can
control your diet you can control you
can't control your facial structure you
can't control your nose maybe you don't
have perfect teeth that's all okay no
one expects it of you we do expect basic
parameters of Health that's the
difference and I think that's where the
disconnect takes place and sometimes
people miss that because I think when we
make fun of you know like obese land
whales that we mean all women want to
look we should look like Chrissy Teigen
I think it's weird and gross now we're
going to talk about as this is
continuing to break and you've been
following this in detail uh Gerald more
than I wanted to the Epstein travel logs
the calendar there's new information
which brings us to Gerald knows things
wanna get AIDS
[Music]
oh I hate that why did you cut back to
me I was fixing my hair yeah
it's it's Gerald knows things there we
go all right so look Jeffrey Epstein's
back in the news uh rightfully so the
Wall Street Journal just released a
report that said maybe people had a
little bit of contact with him uh after
he was a convicted child molester sex
offender I should say but a number of
high-profile people actors and and
people in places of influence and again
this was well after he came it basically
came out and I think it was in 2014 he
was convicted of that right so he
avoided federal charges but let me just
read a quote here he pleaded guilty to
soliciting and procuring a minor for
prostitution that should be a no friends
after this moment kind of thing yeah
yeah but apparently I guess these people
were willing to overlook it he
registered as a sex offender and served
about 13 months in a work release
program which sounds like a little bit
too light of a penalty right so again
the question is also he probably he
probably wouldn't be good at it
isn't that kind of doing manual labor no
he he would definitely crumble he's not
working on the railroad all to live long
day he'll got maybe a half hour in him
tops before you go on my question to you
comment who do you think is implicated
in the calendar if you haven't followed
it yet yeah it'll make all the
references available at live with
creditor.com but you know let's see
there's some foreshadowing right so I'm
just gonna quickly so there's a list of
names and essentially let me just tell
you we're gonna tell you who was in
there we're going to start off with you
know kind of a big name to begin with
but this might be the beginning of the
dam breaking we've all kind of wondered
why there hasn't been release of
information yes who went to Epstein
Island and it seems pretty obvious why
that information hasn't gotten out right
well the celebrities are fun so people
focusing on celebrities because it's fun
to imagine Kevin Spacey Chris Tucker and
Bill Clinton but there's something far
more Sinister afoot yeah when you look
at what actual the government officials
who are there right exactly so let's
start with the first one William Burns
burnsey is the current director of the
CIA oh all right geez and he met with
Epstein in 2014 when he was actually
then Obama's Secretary of State
whoopsies that's government officials
going to meet with a convicted sex
offender who got off with a very light
sentence now might the CIA let me just
say hypothetical or all intelligence
agencies have the ability to perhaps uh
cause security camera footage to
disappear might not be something that
could be within their preview you know I
don't think they're that skilled and I
don't think that's what they do right
right right right no no no no yeah
that's a kitchen out and by the way it's
not like they're members of the CIA you
know what control room Mission Control
you can bring this up with the CIA or
the FBI always get them confused because
they're equally piles of which one
was the one that had thousands of hours
of child pornography on their computers
that wouldn't see I understand that was
the FBI yeah yeah okay
all right so let's go on to the next
person so this is Catherine rumler she's
the chief legal counsel at Goldman Sachs
a small 100 plus year old company that
you might have heard of also former
Obama White House Counsel had dozens of
meetings with Epstein between her time
at the two positions
Epstein introduced her to potential
legal clients as well because that's the
referral that I'm looking for yes child
sex offender says you should do business
with me so maybe give me a call well if
you refer here's the thing well here's
the thing with the Epstein referral
program if you refer six people under
the lead Express the six uh six uh child
prostitutes free ah this is like a
frequent flyer they stamp your card an
island oh okay got it yeah like the fast
lane pass at Disney yeah exactly so
according to a report from The Wall
Street Journal I've got a quote here
Epstein so he Epstein also planned for
her to join a 2015 trip to Paris and a
2017 visit to Epstein's private island
in the Caribbean I was gonna say
Caribbean but then I realized some
people say it that way I know people say
it there's no good way to say Caribbean
no idea which way to go ruler first came
into contact with Epstein while
representing the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation I don't understand this this
is like we almost need like a strange
coincidences show or yeah this is
according to Manny so we've got CIA
we've got Goldman Sachs it gets worse
and then they're and then we've got the
Melinda Bill Gates Foundation
one of your favorite people on the
planet he's a political activist and
former MIT professor and when they asked
about his relationship to Epstein he
replied first response is that it is
none of your business it's all of our
business can you file or anyone's
second is that I knew him and we met
occasionally now here's
don't understand first of all why would
you say just yeah stick with the first
one it's like I'm not answering that
question no comment but I had sex with
underage children
are you not answering never that's all
you get she was delicious
it's either the second half doesn't
record the tablet there first that's
what I do it's confusion it's pattern
disruption
doctor you know I would be my team
Professor yes come come into some
beautiful films here I like sex with
children no I did it again respect the
position
at What occasion would they have to me I
mean this guy's a broke Professor
communist with a capitalist investor
there is no consistency right now it is
true there's plenty that isn't any of
your business right this happened number
one uh yeah they were doing the uh
making a murderer yeah uh film and they
didn't tell you or the series they
didn't tell you that Steve and Avery
like boiled a cat alive and then they
started talking about the prosecuting
attorney had weird sects that really bad
no relevant to the case in other words
that is none of your business in other
words the left who dished dirt the left
who live in tabloid press they love
making things your business that aren't
your business when it relates to federal
crimes however that could involve not
only and keep in mind not only sex that
occurred with underage prostitutes but
could lead to the discovery of people
currently trafficking miners sexually it
is the business of people who could be
at risk there are things that are
private none of your business not if it
involves sex crimes with minors that
could be ongoing no absolutely is that
does that make sense you can comment
below or hit like if you agree with that
because it helps with the algorithm but
I think we could all be on board with
that I think so too and there's at least
a few more people on this list who
disagree with you right he's a good man
to hang out with apparently so Leon
botstein he was the president of Bard
College near New York City and also a
classical music conductor who would have
thought somebody in the Arts could fall
victim to this yes exactly
invited Epstein to Bard College on
several occasions uh botstein attempted
to solicit donations from Epstein for
the college as well I guess he's trying
to work that angle and then uh this
one's this one's interesting I know when
I read this I just like I know that Alex
Jones probably just had a seizure Steven
the Ross Charles
it's Roth Shield Stephen if you go back
in time Shield that's Rothschild the
Rockefellers they all sacrifice children
after raping them okay everybody knows
this it means red shield that's exactly
what it means so he would have so much
fun with this but the chairwoman of
Edmund de Ross Shield group is uh this
person that we just mentioned the Rossi
and married into the famous banking
family also fantastic wine Epstein met
with the Ariana directional between
2013. I'm sure they put that wine to
good use on sex Island 2019 it is a
first growth really so there we go I'm
sure that those children never
appreciated it listen I mean it's a good
thing they don't have the developed
pallets the underage process this is
just I mean how much more evil does it
get does it does it does it no to be
fair from what it seems Epstein wasn't
looking for like nine-year-old children
it seems like they're probably like in
like 16 17 which is of course still
wrong and perverse but it's not the same
as when we're talking about other
pedophiles who work in the
administration perhaps who like young
young children the age of nine right
right so exactly some people are trying
to defend him that way it's still
illegal and we don't know the degree to
which these underage sex trafficking
Rings uh we don't know how far they go
we do know they exist we do know he took
part in them we do know that other
people knew about it we do know that he
was charged with it and we do know that
after he was charged with it people from
the most powerful groups in the world
were still regularly look let me tell
tell you this the Rothschilds they don't
meet with any they don't have an intern
without running a background check we do
that here at this show of course right
you think you think they're going to
travel on a plane with a wealthy I mean
probably claimed he was a billionaire
but still relatively wealthy you think
they wouldn't have known about the
charges they all knew about them that's
why they want it to be none of your
business you think Noam Chomsky didn't
know that this guy was a was a Charged
sex offender you have CIA you have
Goldman Sachs you have Rothschilds you
have people in the most powerful
positions by the way at colleges where
of course you often have minors
attending especially if they graduate
young yeah either way it's it's it's one
of the most crazy stories that I think
we've heard obviously Epstein not
killing himself in prison was the first
kind of crazy Runner to fall but now the
fact that none of this information has
come out until we start to get some of
these leaks people are just like of
course the powerful and rich people in
the world are trying to hide it but
here's the thing we actually have photos
we have travel logs right we have other
testimonials from people that say that
this stuff was going on and existed and
then you got like you said the the
Fantastic three traveling out there all
the time with Bill Clinton and you know
Kevin Spacey and Chris Tucker like it
just it's not Chris Rock right it's
Chris Chris Tucker yeah that's right
he's confused I apologize it's the same
name it's not racist but hopefully what
we'll see is more information coming out
soon on additional people that were
there because we need to know if you're
going to go and associate with somebody
who has been convicted and served kind
of a release program as punishment for
having sex with minors again sounds like
a little bit of a slap on the wrist you
have to pay the penalty for that I'm
sorry that that is one of those crimes
we've talked about you've got to leave
the village I'm sorry you're not safe in
the village anymore and nobody was safe
after that obviously his crimes
continued and they only got worse
how about right now
finding out how these people were
trafficked sexually and putting a step
to them yes where's the CIA with that
where's the FBI without that think about
that they can
enter and put parents at a
parent-teacher conference on a watch
list for having a problem with young
children right transitioning and going
into the wrong bathroom but they can't
the legitimate role of of of their wing
of government should be to protect you
is there anything more important than
protecting kids you do realize that most
underage prostitutes well I shouldn't
say most I don't want to be fat a lot of
them are unwilling participants yeah is
there any forward momentum on stopping
the child sex trafficking ring the
underage sex trafficking Wing I have to
choose my words very carefully because
as we know the FBI or the CIA will put
us on a watch list of course because
[Music]
foreign
portion of them are sex slaves they're
slaves nonetheless
where's the speed we can stop that now
we can at least put a big dent in that
now that's something that is within the
power of the intelligence communities
now and there are more slaves than ever
in history and we're not doing anything
there's this makes pizzagate look
positively mild
when you think about it it does they try
to go they Pizza gate look which very
few people were into the pizza gate they
were to try to do the Q Anon and pizza
game look how crazy this is something
that is verifiable that no one is
denying has happened Pizza gate didn't
involve Goldman Sachs the Rothschilds
the CIA to this degree it's we know it
the only the only the only thing left to
figure out is what degree of punishment
and how much of a proactive approach can
we take to stop this in the future
That's All That Remains What level of
punishment most people none
and how do we use this information to
protect children going forward
the most powerful people in the world
don't want that to happen
that's the story yeah and this has been
I know things
any hole will do
I thought that was a fitting
sign yourself off yes and we're not
going to be able to finish this whole
segment here so we'll finish it on a mug
club and if you are not a member louder
with crowder.com
boom 89 annually you get this wonderful
hand etched girth email you also get
Nick depalo 5 PM you get an extra full
hour of show like we're going to have
today you get a Friday show and like I
said we've commissioned uh stand up
specials and Mr guns and gear more shows
coming down the pike but none of it
happens without viewers like you and I
know NPR says that but they're lying
so unsubsidized viewers like you yes and
when you don't subsidize enough of them
we have to lay them off uh I'm liking
this this uh Vivek Rama Swami ramaswami
from Swami Vivek I hope I get it right
I'm sorry you hit it right it was good
you've got the fresh air and I think he
might actually you know I bet you we
could probably get him on the show I
think it'd be fun yeah I think it would
be fun actually and he's giving the
right not just the right answers but
he's giving the right approach in his
answer yeah which I think is energy too
he's also not 90 years old so that's
also fun he understands how to deal with
the media I don't think there's ever
been anyone more Adept at that than
Andrew Breitbart obviously uh but uh his
sparring with Chuck Todd this weekend
few topics right and talked about gender
talked about the FBI all these things
that people would say are third rails
right oh Republicans will seem way too
far right if they talk about defunding
the FBI or that children shouldn't
transition what I love is that this guy
Vivek leans right into it but makes sure
that it's presented as the reasonable
argument which it is which brings us to
this week's installment of the Flying V
hey
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
correct that's right yes which by the
way a Flying V could never work
it's not possible in the history of
sports no it can't it has never and will
never work because if it did work they
would just use it all the time and Aki's
a random sport a lot like the UFC right
it's chaotic you don't call a play yeah
you have to respond hey guys let's go
behind the net and call the Flying V but
they're pummeling us yeah yeah but they
did nail it when bringing in the the
hockey Consultants with the knuckle Puck
that's right I mean credit where
credit's due yes yes it is very by the
way that's where you pick up the best
hockey players is in South Central LA uh
on the basketball
it's not the kind of shooting that I
think takes about down there
but but this this idea today of picking
the puck up on your stick yeah it's
about 10 years old I think now maybe 20.
guy at the University of Michigan did
that yeah that's amazing it is pretty
that in full pace of a game and then
stuff at the net yeah on the palette of
your stick yeah well that's what uh
that's what this uh Vivek did but
figuratively yes uh all right so here's
kind of some exchanges here you have
host uh Chuck Todd two first names and
look if you have children like I would
say this is a PG-13 okay
[Music]
Chuck
so no idea what he's talking about
you'll watch the clip we're gonna have
to watch so Chuck Todd Came Out Swinging
sorry I meant objective journalisting uh
implying that Vivek was Fanning the
Flames of division your rhetoric can
sound uniting
and your answer just now but then you
you say the following things the trans
movement has become a cult we need to
abandon climate religion in America I
definitely find the idea of systemic
racism revolting I say this how do you
square those statements
with unification these are divisive
times this is a polarizing time we're
pretty evenly divided on these cultural
issues how do you unite do you unite the
country when you're essentially
denigrating the views of half of the
country yeah the views of half the
country is that children should
transition
that's not true no but even if it's true
Chuck you just made your own argument
right you'd integrate the other half of
the views of the country and how do you
unite people when you're doing that it's
just here's the thing two can play at
that game but here's the difference okay
um half the country has changed the
landscape of beer recently but like
that's half the country yeah you try and
act as though half the country believe
that six-year-olds should transition or
you try and act as though half the
country support abortion up until
including birth period or as though half
the country actually know about the
Paris uh accord or sorry the code of yes
Paris according support the idea of
completely eliminating fossil fuels and
forcing everybody to electric cars and
they would like to see five dollar gas
across the country that is not half the
country say this started off and say hey
why are you insulting half the country
which they do only they're actually
referring to a much smaller subset of
the country two acts of deception that
take place there ramaswami fired back
with a very good response this is how
you handle it and made sure left no
doubt now you're still going to have a
percentage of people who don't agree
with those are what we call crazy people
leftists but he made sure that anyone
watching and there aren't many people
watching is Chuck Tai but I'm just doing
this for the sake of argument
you made sure that anyone watching here
he's hearing his argument understands
that wait a second transitioning
children is not a good idea and it's
unscientific
here you go let's take the touchiest of
those subjects right now on the trans
issue I think that when a kid says that
I'm born into the wrong body that my
gender doesn't match my biological sex
more often than not that is a case of a
mental health disorder that doesn't mean
you disrespect that person it means
they're crying out for help I met with
two young women who regret the decisions
they made going through double
mastectomies one a hysterectomy chemical
intervention now trying to teach kids
across the country that when you're
struggling inside going through
adolescence yes that involves some
struggle we live in a cultural moment
today where adults are affirming that
confusion rather than actually ever
treating them compassionately that's
cruelty
that was great if you know what you know
what here here's the thing most hosts
would try to interrupt he didn't give
him an opening he did he kept going very
coherent he wasn't yelling he wasn't
doing anything to make him go okay now
stop stop stop yeah right and he tried
to kind of at the end when he slowed
down and he started to kind of finish
his statement but that's how you do it
if you sit there and go um you know well
uh it just leaves the opening yeah he
stuck the landing with cruelty because
that's what's coming back yep that's the
argument that'll come back his way isn't
it cruel yeah your position nope I'm
taking that position yeah now it's
removed from you as a as a weapon great
answer do you know what else he did
really well and you've heard me talk
about this in the past because Chuck
Todd right just threw up a laundry list
right and he even threw up the umbrella
like trans pretty general climate change
yeah we talk about this mixed martial
arts um uh pop Crowder a really good
fighter does what takes the fight
to the other person takes it yeah and
takes it to where there where they're
stronger so where they're stronger so he
went let's take the most sensitive issue
right there uh or I think I can't
remember the term he used he said the
most kind of hot the most controversial
issue right there let's talk about so in
other words didn't just go uh trans
because that could that could include
Brittany Greiner that could include Leah
Thomas that could include Kate Caitlyn
Jenner he went to the matter of policy
and was specific where he knew very few
Americans would have disagreement right
that's important when they try and give
you this broad generalization right
paint you with this broad brush you go
okay let me take a scalpel and I'm gonna
pick my spot so then at now right away
Todd is on defense and what he tries to
do right is the oh isn't it hypocritical
they do this all the time yeah so you
don't like socialism what about roads
what about the fire department huh they
don't understand the idea of goods
Commodities versus rights as though this
actually works here's what Todd did he
then tried to say that passing laws not
allowing parents to transgender kids
isn't small government isn't that big
government huh isn't it big hey making
murder illegal why do you want a big
government it's that same kind of straw
man watch him handle it what makes it
compassionate though to uh pass a law
that denies a parent uh making their own
health care decision for their kid
that's the part of this that doesn't
sound very conservative in small
governments oh isn't that clever yeah
that doesn't sound conservative and
small government uh hold on a second
parental rights mean that the parent has
the right to tell their child not to
transition just like the parents have
the right to not feed their child
Captain Crunch if they want to make sure
that they actually have a healthy
breakfast right didn't catch Vivek
because he replied very well
but look there isn't a state in this
Union that allows you to smoke an
addictive cigarette before the age of 18
that allows you to get a tattoo before
the age of 18. that's a body altering
change that a kid May later regret in
life so I think it is perfectly
reasonable to say that if you're after
18 years old you're free to decide
whatever you want to do that's what it
means to live in a free country but
below the age of 18 I think it's
perfectly legitimate to say that we
won't allow genital mutilation or
chemical castration through puberty
blockers
okay so checked out true
[Laughter]
we'll get into more we're a little bit
over time this is it also makes sense
because uh we're not going to discuss
the rest of this on YouTube anyway so
please hey share the show if you're on
Rumble leave a comment obviously smash
Rumble button let people know about
Rumble but we are going to continue to
louder with crowder.com where the tech
then changes from Chuck Todd to the what
the patronizing he goes on hey well hold
on a second
Vivek do you actually even understand
what gender is that's the route we now
go so we tried one path cut off tried
another path oh hypocrite cut off now
he's trying the you don't know anything
path and it doesn't work we're going to
discuss it it's a hot button issue thank
you Rumble YouTube piss off
foreign